says that garfield from port elizabeth
okay you see rook takes pawn being
played south africa wonders why i make a
big fuss about the chess and not give
him some attention oh we have a jealous
cat
and uh okay so whilst i was talking we
have a big flurry of trades and
everything is level now this is one of
the most drawish positions in chess you
will ever see uh simply all the pawns
are getting traded the rooks have come
off david anton knows his tournament is
about to be over duda is
one or two moves away now from the
semi-finals we're just going to see the
players repeat there's simply not enough
material left to deliver checkmate and
there we go we have the draw
will we see some celebration from young
christopher do not know he just
runs off and look at david anton
disappointed of course
i think this was the first time dave
danton has made it to the knockout stage
but it ends here in the coach finals and
the charity cup now christoph duda has
been on fire today